翻訳: Koichiro Yoda
校正: Hiroko Kawano
（演奏：太鼓 銅羅 シンバル）
（演奏停止）
（拍手）
（演奏）
（演奏停止）
（拍手）（歓声）
（演奏）
（演奏停止）
（拍手）（歓声）
（演奏）
（拍手）
（演奏停止）
（演奏）
（演奏終了）
（拍手）
どうですか？
（笑）
（中国語）はじめまして
神戸華僑總會舞獅隊の
盧健良と申します
（日本語）はじめまして
私は神戸華僑總會舞獅隊の
盧健良と申します
よろしくお願いします
（拍手）
今見て頂いたのは
中国の方でも南方系の獅子
「南獅（ナンスー）」と言います
日本の獅子舞と違って獅子の頭が
一回り大きかったりですとか
楽隊も「太鼓 銅鑼 シンバル」と
非常に賑やかな音で構成されています
謂われとしましても
日本の獅子舞同様に
獅子に噛まれると 無病息災 商売繁盛と
非常に験を担ぐ祝いの舞とされています
すみません
今日は 中ほどの方々 噛みに行けなくて
（笑）
この獅子舞なんですけども
我々演者はこの獅子頭を単にかぶって
踊っているだけではなくて
実は 基本的な動作というのが
８つあります
我々は「八態（パータイ）」
と言っております
その８つの状態なんですけど
「喜 怒 哀 楽」
「静 動 驚 疑」
というふうに
基本の動作が ８つあります
今日は 比較的ダイナミックな演技を
中心としているんですけども
獅子舞も実は ストーリー性を持たせた
演舞というのも多くございます
例えば 獅子が
好物のものを探しに行きまして
その好物を見つけた時にどんな味がするのか
楽しみになったりだとか
それを取るに至るまでに
「静」の動き「動」の動きを含めたり
それを本当に食べられるのかと
疑ったりとか
匂いを嗅いで
ちょっと驚いてみたりとか
そういった基本的な動作を習得した上で
演者それぞれが個性を出し合って
表現を創意工夫しているところです
こんな獅子舞と 私との出会いというのが
私がちょうど５歳のときです
私はこの日本の神戸で生まれて育ってきた
中国国籍を持つ「華僑」と呼ばれる —
そして私は３世にあたります
おじいちゃんおばあちゃん
そしてお父さんお母さんがいて私がいて
３世にあたります
[華僑]
ひと昔前ですと
華僑同士の結婚式とか宴会で
この中国獅子舞が非常に多く呼ばれて
獅子を舞うことがたくさんありました
そこで私も初めて見たときに
大きくなったら いつかこれがしたいな
と思う気持ちがありまして
高校生のときにこの隊に入隊しました
そして時が経って いつの間にか
隊長を任されるようになりまして
そこでどんどん歳を重ねるごとに
この獅子舞の楽しさというか
魅力を知ることができました
先ほどみなさんにお話をした「八態」も
そのうちの一つなんですけれども
単純に動いているのではなくて
獅子ってこういう楽しいところが
あるんだというのを知[りました]
ただ ここ神戸で活動している
中国獅子舞なんですけれども
[中国]本土の方に行けば
広東省ですとか [台湾]とか
隣国でいうと
シンガポール マレーシア
そういったところでも 実は
中国獅子舞は非常に庶民に密着していて
至極当たり前のように
獅子舞が行われているんです
世界大会まであるぐらいなんです
ただ やはりここ日本で
この中国獅子舞をやっていく上で
なかなか認知度が低くて
我々華僑の中においても
中国獅子舞の意識がなくて
というのも 我々３世 もしくはこの後世
４世 ５世になってきますと
やはり日本社会で住んでいるものなので
出会う方は日本の方が非常に多いですし
日本の方と結婚することが多いので
「結婚式に獅子舞を呼ぶ」という認識は
ほとんど今はなくなってきているんですね
なので 我々も もっともっと
この中国獅子舞というのを広めたいけれども
なかなか華僑の中でも
それが伝承していけない —
続けていけないという
ジレンマを抱えることになっていました
ただ 海外の方と出会う
きっかけがありまして
他の団体を見ていますと
別に華僑にこだわらないで
獅子舞をずっと続けられている方々
団体が多くありました
私もそこで改めて自分が 何かこう —
華僑 中国国籍とか
そういうのにこだわってた自分が
ちょっと違うんじゃないかなと思いました
というのも 僕は
ここ神戸で生まれ育って
神戸というのは もちろん
我々のような中国系のものもいれば
韓国の方だったり インドの方だったり
欧米の方だったり
本当に異国民が一つの町で共存する
そんな街なんだなということを知って
いろんな出演先で皆さんにこの中国獅子舞を
知ってもらうだけではなくて
そこで知り合った人たち —
興味を持った人たちに門戸を広げて
[共存]
神戸らしく国際色豊かなメンバーが
この神戸華僑總會舞獅隊として
共に一つの伝統文化 伝統芸能を一緒に
後世に伝承 継承していっても
いいのではないかなと思うようになりました
最後に
今日見て頂いて 楽しかったとか —
噛まれて嬉しかったという方も
おられると思いますが
もしこの中に１人でも
もしくは２人でも
興味を持っていただいて
やってみたいという人がおられれば
ぜひ我々と一緒に
一つの伝統文化 伝統芸能の
伝承者となって
一緒に担い手となって頂ければと思います
ご清聴ありがとうございました
（拍手）